one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's father yep your pricks the bark he
frowned
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till
two
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are it's one more
drink
with mark and sam good to be back feels
like it's been a whole
a whole month but it's only been a week
a lot's been happening man
uh it's good to see you you too you too
i was just watching the uh
i don't know why i guess because i
missed stand up and i missed the clubs
in new york i was watching
the roast of rich voss oh my god that
was a great roast
it's on youtube and i'm only halfway
through because the whole thing is like
six hours but norton
murders so many yeah he killed it quinn
murdered everyone
everyone florentine had an unbelievable
set i haven't gotten there yet that's
what i keep hearing he's the he's the
breakout he's the standout but i haven't
gotten there yet
man i'm just loving it just the
camaraderie and the inside jokes it's
bringing me back
yeah it's classic that's a great roast
check it out on youtube
vloss is also amazing at the end too
it's it's great
i'm excited i'm excited but yeah so much
to talk about first of all what are you
sipping on there fat man
what am i sipping on oh that looks milky
and gay
what is that it's not it's not what i
call it
uh i go by the white russian oh
aka the caucasian yes
little lebowski mood you know i was
reading up on this
[ __ ] i was reading up on it it
started as a black russian
and then they lightened it up it was
like a black drink and then
uh they became white and stole a lot of
the thunder they should call it the
elvis
nice nice just don't die on the toilet
um
so wait why was it black because it was
just kahlua
and vodka they didn't put any cream in
it ah
well you know i guess much like rock and
roll white had to come in and fix it
i'm joking but uh
white people did invent basketball all
right
but yeah that's interesting
but why russian it's i guess vodka okay
that makes it it's created in belgium it
has nothing to do with russian i don't
know why it's called the white russian
or the black russian
there you go this is the question is the
danish from denmark
it's all another it's another question
for another episode
what are you sipping on i love a white
russian but again
two of them and you're like all right
all right yeah
i'll let you know old-fashioned oh
you did the orange peel too oh yeah i
threw a little garnish
not vermouth bitters splash of water
bourbon ice cube yeah did you do any
sugar in there or no
i didn't do it i don't want the sugar
all right so it's not really an
old-fashioned it's like a it's like a
it's like a bourbon with bitters yeah
all right all right i guess what the
sugar though who needs it it's
it's i like it if it's a manhattan i go
i feel like because of
uh mad men everyone was like
old-fashioned because don draper is cool
as hell but
i'm all about i'm all about a manhattan
i like the vermouth man
manhattan is a superior drink i think
for sure uh the old fashioned's like
i'm going golfing you know i'm in
seersucker i'm at the country club
it's like a mint julep yeah [ __ ] it uh
dude speaking of lebowski one of my
favorite movies i feel like everybody
loves that movie it's a cold classic
check out what i got
the movie was based on frame baby
whoa wow look at that howard hawks
yeah the big sleep uh in french
yeah pretty cool don't love the movie
but the posts are so cool
i love the vlog old posters are amazing
i don't know why
we kind of lost that now it's like
explosions in the rock
with a gun i was all about posters when
i was like can you ever just go through
like blockbuster and you like swipe
poster to poster
oh dude that they even had posters at
walmart like
yeah remember it was like a poster
convention or like a rock club what do
you call those places with like records
posters black lights that's why i got
this i got it's like a place in l.a
where it's just a record store but they
have classic
posters too so i was in heaven just
scrolling through these man
yeah we had one of those in new orleans
called the mushroom and it was like a
big deal you could get a
weed pipe you can get a tie-dye shirt a
chain wallet you know [ __ ] like that
weird stuff like brass knuckles
rolling papers you know and it was so
we're going to the mushroom it was like
a big deal
brad's knuckles i've been there that
isn't it on like [ __ ] it's near tulane
right it's
right on broadway right i've been there
i've been there oh yeah there you go
yeah it's hilarious yeah those old
posters man like the vertigo poster it
doesn't get any better than
the vertigo poster the movie oh that is
a classic rear window too
like all the psycho's a cool poster yeah
that's the uh um
great quote from the from the big sleep
which is like
you know obviously he's always drinking
on the case such a cool pi but he goes
you can have a hangover from other
things in alcohol i had one from a woman
or from women it says but i [ __ ] love
that that
line sums up your whole act
wow that is that's a perfect blurb
that's hilarious another one uh it
looked like a nice neighborhood to have
bad habits in
oh so many good that that book is some
class i was like that's like the one if
you're going to get into raymond
chandler you should start with the big
sleep
yeah they're all great but that's like
the good start off one
you watch this movie just for those
lines let's be honest i don't care about
the plot
no i just want to hear some cool ass
lines give me the lines
oh that's the best speaking of that
speaking of plot and
and noir and all that i finished thirds
party by the way
oh yeah how how many episodes in do the
whole show
i'm i'm i'm about to finish it i'm on
the season four in the middle
oh i'm only on season two oh geez i'm
blowing past you i'm loving it
it's great i i got to tell you at first
i was like yeah that's a little hipstery
i don't know but then i realized oh
they're making fun of them yes and
then i got into it i love it i love any
like any pi type show doing it that's
why i love lebowski it's like a pi thing
but done
with like a like a dirtbag hippie sleuth
i love that it's like
they went the different way you know i
love that and i don't know if it caught
on
out of the gate like i think lebowski
was uh
it was like it did okay in the box
office but then when they hit dvds it
went nuts
well it was that and kingpin i think
like the same year and i think they were
like it was like two bowling comedies at
the same time and people were like all
right
i might have been the same year but it's
around the same time and uh
yeah i mean i remember seeing that in
the theater and just like loving it even
though i didn't fully i was too young to
fully get it
which one lebowski yeah yeah no totally
i mean
the rug brings the room together the
robe the white rush the car yeah it was
a lot a [ __ ] john torturo when you're
a kid you're like what the hell's this
guy doing
and then john goodman is going
eight-year-olds dude like it's amazing
and as a kid you're like i don't get
this but it's [ __ ] i mean you just
get that he's
like has cartoonish enough elements that
a kid can laugh you have john goodman
just being allowed like shut the [ __ ] up
and that's funny to a kid still
totally totally yeah shut the [ __ ] up
donnie and then
but then the scenes were like jeff
bridges is floating to the bob dylan
song you're like what is
i mean that's complete cohen brothers
it's going we're doing what we want
oh dude the kenny rogers thing is insane
yeah when he gets
roofied oh my gosh
sam elliott they always have to have
that god character in there that like
narrates the whole thing
yeah i loved it [ __ ] dude that fargo is
still my favorite cone brothers movie
but that's number two i think
yeah fargo is up there but no country
yeah that's it's in the mix they've made
so many good movies though dude i know
i know even their okay movies are like
great percent it's almost like a carlin
special even the whole thing there's
something in there you can grab
i like true grit man i just i just like
the movies love it love true grit i
liked uh
hudsucker proxy i loved oh i never saw
that one that's paul newman right
oh dude it's great paul newman uh tim
robbins
it's all about the guy it's all about an
entrepreneur and you got to see it it's
great
i gotta check it out art deco wait so
what are you drinking
oh i told you oh yeah an old fashioned
i'm sorry that's already hitting me
sorry
wow that's a bad sign early in the
episode uh
i should clarify i'm in front i'm going
new orleans bars now i realize look i'm
from a town that's covered in
dive bars i might as well this is my
whole childhood or
i'm embarrassed by the way that that
just happened oh
you're fine we're it's a drinking show
yeah shocking it hasn't happened more
i'm gonna have to get used to it um this
is this is snake and jakes did you ever
go there and you're good yeah
okay opens at 3 a.m it's
at snake and jake's christmas lounge
it's in the middle of a residential area
uptown new orleans
everything's cheap as balls they still
sell schlitz in the can
i mean it's you end up there you're
doing blow you're [ __ ] an old lady
and you're fending like a jazz musician
she's going to rob you at the end
it's [ __ ] experience yeah fist
fighting
rooting tooting great great real
alcoholics dive bar
i remember friar tux at uh in new
orleans i remember i
nearly had an incident there i remember
uh this woman
mouthed help and i was like oh [ __ ] like
some creepy guy was really in her [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm young enough to be
confident enough to be like i could help
so i got over there and i was like why
don't you leave the lady alone man he
like looked at me
and he was like a scary looking dude but
i was so confident that he was just like
all right i was like damn that was
insane that was for you
that's worked for me twice i'm never
gonna do it again
well you are you're a tall guy and you
got you're very uh
brooding looking you got the eyebrows
the dark
if i'm rocking a jacket they can't tell
that there's nothing going on under here
you know if i have something like puffy
on there like all right
you know but like if i'm if they see any
of my actual frame they're like oh
you're [ __ ] dead right you know a bag
of coat hangers over here
but wait a minute did you i hope the
lady
was uh appreciative and gave you she was
for something she was i don't remember
if i got a number but i do remember um
yeah yeah she was appreciative i mean
[ __ ] i was i was also just young and be
like that's weird that's chivalry man a
woman asked for help you [ __ ] step
in right what was the second time
second time um [ __ ]
it's blurry i was pretty drunk but it
was my lovely side and i was going home
with a girl and
i was gonna drop her off at home because
we were going uptown i was gonna drop
her off
and uh this guy got in front of us and
she goes she's stealing our cab and i
was like i [ __ ] hate when people do
that she was like i hate when people do
that
so i said i'm gonna say something and i
said hey man
uh we were already here you know i was
very polite about it even though i had a
few in me
and he goes [ __ ] off and i go what the
[ __ ] do you i got like angry i was like
what the [ __ ]
because she was there i was like what do
i do yeah i was like i was like the [ __ ]
do you just say
and and i go you're a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] i got in his face
and he's with a girl too and i could
tell that he was like this guy's nuts so
he just [ __ ] ran away
wow hey yeah and i brought her home it
was like that was the thing
good for you man she was like that was
she was i feel like i could tell she was
bad but she goes that was incredible and
i was just like ooh this is not a good
this is the woman who expects this [ __ ]
right and i can't deliver this regularly
this was
like i'd say one twice in a lifetime
thing
wow i bluffed i went all in i went all
in with a two and a five
but hey you you won the pot you want to
get home
yeah man that's that's amazing but he
had no confidence
right right wow that's so cool i mean
even though like we're not violent guys
we're not tough guys
i'm a [ __ ] white russian yeah yeah
i was i was at the cellar one night mike
yard you know tough
comic funny dude he's tough i mean he's
been shot he's like you know from east
new york and i remember we're talking
about
he ordered a bailey's irish cream on the
rocks and i was like ooh
tough guy and he goes i could still kick
your ass and i was like
yes you can there's nothing you can say
no there's nothing you can say when
someone says i can kick your ass you're
like that's the end i guess
yeah that's it because he probably could
and uh
nobody wants that but yeah no but even
when you did that to that guy with the
cab how good did you feel in that cab
ride home
i felt great but i had like this image
of like terminator 2 robert patrick just
[ __ ] running behind it and i was like
ah
i would have shown my true colors no i i
felt good for that moment but i also
like
that's the dangers of booze is you get
confident
and there's also people like that who
like like you want to go and the guy
just like gets into a [ __ ] muay thai
pose and like oh
[ __ ] that's a crushing thing
yeah like i don't you don't know who's
knows [ __ ] jiu-jitsu or who went to
summer camp with uh
chuck liddell or whatever the hell it is
you know so like
you never know it could be the
scrawniest pipsqueak guy and he knows
how to do
a muay thai it's great it's almost like
in new york you kind of felt comfortable
like
talking a little bit of [ __ ] because
this was like pre-mma
craze and like new york you know most
people aren't carrying guns here you
know so
uh but then you go to the midwest that's
why everyone's so [ __ ] polite
yes yeah bless your heart that's cause
like i don't know what the hell you're
packing you know so i don't
so true and that's the thing about new
orleans where i grew up every guy's
wearing a polo
tucked in with shorts and a woven belt
boat shoes
sunglasses with the weird dangly rope
thing
and they got the swoop haircut but these
guys they go like
fishing and muddin these guys will kick
your ass and like be happy to
like kick your ass with a cigarette in
their mouth you know there's nothing
worse than getting
the [ __ ] kicked at you by a guy in a
vineyard vine shirt you know
yeah yeah exactly he's drinking a
uh what do you call those uh what a
sazerac
and he's got a seersucker blazer on and
he beats the [ __ ] out of you it's
he's got his class ring on brutal
clash rings really who thought those
were a good idea
i know i remember i asked my dad like
should i get that he goes
ugh i'm like all right all right i'm not
getting it oh yeah when your dad is like
a loser you're like all right
all right yeah anytime you see someone
no one's ever been like cool class ring
dude
like no no one's ever gotten a
compliment on one no
never they're huge they they're big and
gaudy they're they're horrible they're
like 300 bucks
and you graduated high school you didn't
win the nba finals dude
but that's the same guy who goes three
touchdowns in the in the game to when
they uh
win the game against holy cross you're
like all right we got it
61.
oh yeah what uh what's going on
give me a pet peeve oh well mine's not
great did i i don't know
i don't know if everyone's gonna agree
with me on this because uh
i think some people will like the guy
who does it but i
hate and i hate it when a friend does
this one
you know you go man you just missed it
this ambulance went by i was like
when your friend goes what it do and you
go
and they all start laughing i hate when
they do the wood what did it do
you know i heard this you've never seen
this
and they go oh cell phone rang and the
movie theater was like paper baby
what was it like and you gotta go ah
it crushes me because you're a written
word comic and you're and
you're watching those that that dude
that same dude is the one who buries you
on stage without any writing
exactly exactly yeah some joe schmoe can
just go what would he do what'd it sound
like and you have to repeat it and now
you're the idiot
yeah ah kills me every time sound effect
guy the police academy guy
yeah but he makes you the police academy
guy because he makes you repeat it
it's a pretty cool move it is a cool
yeah i don't i've never really
experienced it to be honest
well i guess i'm trying to paint a
picture so i really up the
up the sound effect and he nails you on
it
i knew it was a bad one but it i just
don't know it enough
i'm trying to yes i and you but it's i
don't know it enough i haven't i have an
angry one
my pet peeve all right please please so
someone took an old bit of mine
um and it went like viral it's some
[ __ ] british hack
it did my bit verbatim and he claims
he's never seen it but it's like
literally every word is verbatim
wait a minute is this the video game
thing yeah yeah yeah i saw some on this
on twitter about this
yeah yeah so okay it it's got like one
and people just keep re-sharing it so
it's like one guy posted on tick-tock
it's like four million views another guy
puts it on tick tock it's like four
million views
so it's like millions and millions of
views and then i get worried i'm like do
people
not know that i wrote like i don't want
i'm a [ __ ] thief if i you know
right so um this guy
i do some detective work to find this
guy and
he's a real prick he's a real piece of
[ __ ] and he's
he's like oh they always say the same
[ __ ] to you when you bust these people
they're like
i've never heard of you and like they
want to neg you on top of it they go
i i'm not familiar and i'm like well you
did it verbatim
like it's a 35-second bit that you
didn't miss one
you threw in an um but other than that
it's all
and and it's really like these
talentless
morally bankrupt [ __ ] that
don't understand that we put work
and hone material and try it out and
write it
and then go back and try it again until
it's where we want it
and they're just like oh yeah no i want
to like [ __ ] you
right exactly wait wait so what is the
video is it him saying it or is it yeah
it's him saying that
it's him saying the joke i don't know
wow he laughs
from someone else or he's turning on
stage almost i don't even know how he's
doing it but it's
him doing my material so i find this guy
through some the funniest part is when
you're like you piece of [ __ ] and
they're like i'm 15. i'm like all right
fine whatever
you know so uh anyway i get to this guy
man he goes on and on but like i say you
know you're despicable i write you know
uh
intellectual property theft i'm throwing
some words out there but i go ever said
you should have a good
explanation for this and he writes like
nothing is ever achieved by being rude
so perhaps consider a less
confrontational and accusing message in
future
none of us have ever seen the joker film
and yeah they did in the joker too is my
is it my [ __ ] hour special for comedy
central positive influence and it's in
the joker i'm like
you've never seen the joker okay fine
but like it's verbatim
yeah jesus uh
the way we run our content involves a
weekly live stream where we allow our
viewers to submit their favorite jokes
it's like i don't understand what this
is okay but it went viral and you're
using my
they don't understand how jokes work
like if you didn't come up with it you
don't get to just steal it like it's
your joke
i know and all you got to say is i like
this comic
sam morel here's his bit and then it's
then great now it's viral
and people hear it and i'm not trying to
[ __ ] on all these like instagram meme
guys because there's people out there
like tank sinatra who are writing their
own [ __ ]
those memes are their own and if they
use someone else they credit them like
they're actually putting original
content out there there's good people
like tank
and then there's people like [ __ ] jerry
or the fat jew
or just like morally bankrupt they're
bad
people who are just like i'll make money
i can build up a following doing this
right money yeah their talent is
actually seeing
what's funny and then marketing it as if
it's theirs that's their talent not
actually comedic talent or creative
talent but
tanks tank's great love tank but that's
the problem with these 15 year olds is
they
are they grew up with the internet so
they just think it's this [ __ ]
playground and this
this grocery store they can pick and
choose whatever they want but it had to
come from somewhere you queefs
somebody had to write that [ __ ] yeah it
really it sucks
and it's like i try to be good about it
like when someone takes a photograph of
me i try to find their instagram handle
and credit them like
people these are careers for people so
yeah if you're stealing
you're stealing their work without
crediting them
for crediting them for their work is
what you're doing you know you know
who's really hating this conversation is
porn stars they're like
oh did people enjoy your [ __ ]
welcome to my world that's my whole life
i haven't paid for porn in 10 years
maybe 20.
20 yeah i i i haven't either but here's
the difference between porn and what we
do
anybody can go [ __ ] on screen you get it
in one take jake you're done we got to
rehearse this [ __ ] do the road
write it replay it say it again listen
to it bomb with it tweak it
so it is a little different it is funny
you say porn stars because
i was about to go on this rant in my
head i was like uh
you know how like this like based
culture that dopamine rush has
brought up uh i think ugliness in us
because peop
especially same with you think of
twitter how people just pander because
like remember when twitter first started
and it was all about like just telling a
joke and getting likes and then it
became like
this has got to stop and you're like a
hundred thousand likes over this has got
to stop
you know so i was gonna say like this
like based culture has
really brought about like a lack of
originality ugliness
pandering horseshit uh yes
i'll say one good thing it's about a lot
of aspects on instagram
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with that a lot of likes going that way
but for the most part it's bad
yeah yes yeah they earned those aspects
they did the squats
or they were born with a gift but yes i
completely surgery maybe
they got they got the implants all right
either way you're really dedicated to
your art
you put your body on the line yes here
here
and no i don't follow you or actually
like it because uh
i don't want anybody to see my paper
thank you for you you're doing the
lord's work
lady but oh i forgot my point you got me
thinking about fat juicy asses
well what i was gonna say is that these
people it's like they're stealing
it's like they're stealing drugs and
selling they're like dealers they're
like drug dealers
and like what do i do i'm like what
you're stealing and dealing is what
you're doing
yes exactly oh yeah you're wrong jokes
you're so right with the uh the likes
though it creates this weird thing where
that's what people are liking we'll just
go that direction so integrity
is so lost these days it's just like oh
i know i've never cared about
activism before but now it's popular so
i'll jump on it and you're like
then you call them on it they go no i've
always cared about this so you're like
are you lying are you delusional which
one is it and it's right
because we haven't changed we're the
same idiots
it's so bad i mean we've talked about a
million times but just the idea of like
not being face to face
man just like putting [ __ ] out like you
don't think and it's not just in terms
of cruelty but it's in terms of like
being who like was that who you really
are behind the keyboard i think who you
really are is around people
right but none of this [ __ ] is real so
you become this person on twitter where
it's like oh i'm just like
you know this is how i i feel but it's
like but you're alone with a gadget is
that really you
you did you think that through twitter
should have an are you sure button like
it should have a send and then
are you sure yes you know i completely
agree you're 100
right and i've always said that twitter
is like a laser pointer
for a cat we just get all engaged we get
all worked up the heart rate's going
and then before you know it you're like
oh this is nothing there's nothing here
it's not real
and now you're just climbing the wall
because you think there's a red dot on
it's not even there
i think i like it i think we're making
some interesting points here should we
should we shout out the uh
the emails because people are sending us
a lot of emails please i read i probably
read 50 of them tonight
oh man all right we're ahead of may i uh
we i should say that our patreon will be
coming out this week so keep an eye open
patreon.com
slash one more drink pod that's
patreon.com
one more drink pod and you can email us
at
one more drink with uh mark and sam at
gmail.com and also
make sure you subscribe to uh us on
apple but there's two someone else i
guess helped us out before we got our
producer
harry in the mix and uh harry uploaded
us so we you can stop doing that we got
uh we got someone doing this so one more
drink with mark and sam
uh that's the one you want not just one
more drink one more drink with mark and
sam that's the one you want to subscribe
to an apple that's us
here here well well done leave us a
review
yeah and thank you for all the emails i
mean they were sweet and
funny and thoughtful so i appreciate you
guys because we know the email address
is about three
pages long so just typing all that in we
appreciate
you want to do you want to do one then
i'll do one sure sure
all right let me pull it up here i
picked two i liked
for different reasons all right let me
know if you want me to go or you want to
go
you go all right all right now i want to
say it was hard to pick there's so many
good ones but
the two that jumped out and grabbed my
taint for some reason
was adam lambert adam lambert 109
at outlook.com i don't know if i was
supposed to give that out but
you said you don't give the emails sorry
sorry beep that there harry
um but uh by the way first can i just
say we got one
some from iran we got some from ireland
we got some from belgium i mean like
jersey we're all over the road with
these emails which i love
i love it all right hey guys huge fan of
the pot do i read the whole thing
i don't know if it's like too long how
long is it ah
it's about a paragraph and a half i'll
read it read it
all right huge fan of the podcast
wouldn't mind a commentary on a joke or
two i wrote i'm so lazy it's just gonna
be
the last two i wrote in my notes i'm
trying comedy nowadays i was a former
child star yeah i was in adult films
i just happen to be a child actor that's
funny all right
here's the joke kids hate
going to school but two types of kids
were probably
pissed about doing school at home online
and there's
the two types are soon to graduate prom
kids
and would be school shooters i knew he
was going to school
yeah i knew he was going to school
shooter had to do it but here's how he
connects it this is why he's good
so we got the two types that are missing
out on school because of online classes
graduate prom kids and school shooters
it's the same thing it was supposed to
be your special day
you'd remember it forever and you were
finally gonna get
jessica that's dark but i like it
i like that he connected him oh
yeah prom so you're like a prom king and
also a school dude that works that's
funny yeah pretty good pretty good get
jessica's not a bad little connection
there with the
the third punch ruling some connection
to like carrie cause you're covered in
blood
yeah yeah they're all going to laugh at
you
and then he's like he said is stand up
doing stand up at 27
too late i've done like three mics no
no it's not just do it if you want to do
it just do it i say yeah worry about it
i mean there's no too late if it's if we
do what you want to do in your life man
i mean if you love it i mean
you'll know in a few years if it's
working or not you know uh but i think
if if
do this if you love it yeah i mean
because you're not gonna make it anyway
no just kidding but it's so tough that
you know just
if you love it and it makes you happy do
it you know
yeah all right you hit me there all
right let's see
um david kilbride
good morning gentlemen i haven't read
this one yet i have a hard time knowing
if something's a one-liner or a premise
here's one let me know if it's hacky
women who participate in gangbangs are
the ultimate people pleasers
oh i like it that's fun believe it or
not it's tough to google a gang bang
joke to see if it's been done before
i can imagine love david all right that
was nice
give me another all right all right dave
even that's that tag is funny it's tough
to google gank that's that's a good tag
it's tough to google a gang bang yeah
that's uh maybe the thing is
i google gangbang and i never finished
the rest of the joke ah
there you go something like that all
right you got that david write that down
all right uh this guy benjamin johnson
he go he gave us some jokes that's just
at the beginning but not the end but i
think there's some stuff here
fighting sleep is like trying not to
come
all right that could be a bit it could
be something there fighting sleep is
like trying not to come
you're in bed uh there's a lot of
similarities there
yeah both of them put you to sleep i
don't know
fighting sleep is like trying not to
come yeah there might be some way like
uh
especially if you're in a relationship
or something right
right right uh
especially at your parents house yeah
fighting sleep is like trying not to
come
all right uh country music doesn't allow
swearing
but it has [ __ ] right there in the name
that's cute
it's cute people like to complain about
planes taking off late
but i but have you ever thought about
what the world would be like
if it was made up of a bunch of people
just like you
most things including planes wouldn't
even have been developed because we're
not even as close to a smart
so we really have no right to complain
oh that's kind of heavy
that's interesting yeah i mean i
definitely uh i've had that thought and
then i've also traveled enough to be
like
no i'm right no i agree i mean it's it's
we take a lot for granted that's right
well it's kind of similar to louie's bit
about uh
you know everything's great and nobody's
happy you know he's on the plane he's
like oh the plate was 20 minutes late
he's like oh yeah then you sit in a
chair in the sky
you know yeah it's so true yeah it's it
is amazing like
you ever just like if i'm [ __ ] pissed
about a flight it's more about me like
missing a show or something if
it's just right but or if it's like
feels like it's the airline being
incompetent i'm never like
well i could have made this airline
that's never the issue that's a good
point it's also if like they're like
or they're like oh we oversold our
flight i'm like well that's that's the
[ __ ] that pisses me off it's not yeah
it's not really the oh [ __ ] we need to
like thaw off the
uh wing or something like that right i
get that
it is sad when uh the things i've said
to like make a flight go faster i'm like
but i'll be fired and uh the the club
won't use me again i've made up all
these lies to like
somehow think they're gonna be like all
right we'll start the plane up i get i
go into like rich white lady mode
the toledo funny bone might bump your
weekend we have a first clack
we have a first-class ticket right this
way yeah exactly but i sold out a show i
swear to god i have merch
uh one more from him and he said uh
people will
people would call someone gay for
watching trans porn but it's actually
the straightest porn there is you watch
dudes [ __ ] chicks but trans porn is a
hot chick
[ __ ] a hot chick still a dick but no
man
face i think regular porn is gayer
here's my rebuttal my rebuttal is
the dick is so that i have like a it's
like a
it's like a video game i'm like that's
my dude that's like it's like a first
person shooter you're like
and they give you a dude that's better
than you it's like you know it's like
it's like halo or call of duty and
you're like jack you're like that's me
that's who i get to be in this scenario
right
yeah i can't picture being a chick with
a dick that's just not me
good point yeah i don't mean to poo poo
this premise here i'm just saying that's
where i come in i'm not looking at the
dick i'm not looking at the dick like
sweet dick i'm looking like all right
that's my character
you know sweet dick is the worst uh
whiskey out there by the way
but yeah yeah you're right that's true
the dick is you you you take that guy's
form that's why
interracial porn is tougher because
you're like
guys so not me i'm not i'm not worried
about the interracial part i'm worried
about the
i can't fit into that you know i can't
be that guy
so we need we need to make our own
whiskey and call it sweet dick
yeah which raises the point you bring up
video game here's the bit benjamin this
is the bit
yeah avatar for porn you got your video
game guy you can create a guy with curly
hair
and a bad stubble and whatever
a shitty voice you know and graphics
aren't good enough
were you ever watching those things and
you're just like because they do those
before a porn sometimes it's like a
trailer and you're just like
this is [ __ ] this is avatar it's not
this is the movie avatar not a diamond
this is ridiculous i mean you know so oh
they have like the woman and she's so
fake that you're just like all right i
mean
at this point i mean i'm saying this is
like adult
remember leisure shoot larry remember
that oh god do i
jesus but i'm saying you can create a
your own
player for a video game would it be cool
if you could create your player for a
porn
it would i just think like better like i
think like when they already have sex
robots if you're in that world you're
gonna be like i'm gonna take the sex
robot
yeah that's a good point and also
there's like seinfeld porn and simpsons
porn
and all this [ __ ] i was like oh this
will be awesome i love simpsons
you're like this ladies [ __ ] and
green and white and yellow paint with
the
like marge wig what am i doing here oh
it's also when they have like the
cartoon one you're like you're like hell
yeah take it miss krabappel you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah lois stewie's [ __ ] lois
yeah what do we do with our lives here
it's too much it's like yeah it's too
far
and yeah and uh yeah it's porn is that's
the other thing we're talking about like
the young kids with their likes what are
they going to be like with this porn
it's it's going to [ __ ] their brains up
i know i know it's crazy i can't even
imagine
and look we've we played with fire we're
flying too close to the sun because if
you say
if you told you at 11 or 12
do you want free porn on your basically
on your computer
all day every day you'd go i'd give my
left [ __ ] for that what are you
kidding me i pay a million dollars see
it's
how can they know it's crazy and it's
also like
uh we are flying too close we're flying
too close to the stepson that's what
we're doing
but uh no we're uh no we're uh we're
really
it is i mean like every comics made this
[ __ ] joke but it's the most obvious
thing it's like you were a kid in school
you took out a calculator you did eight
zero zero eight
you did boobs right that was [ __ ]
funny that was how horny we were
yeah we're like boob you know what i
mean
now it's like kids could kids can
literally go to the bathroom and jerk
off
yeah yeah they got porn in their pocket
and women have no idea
how glad how lucky they are that they're
not women aren't really into porn i
don't think
i mean there's a select few i don't
think so not like us yeah i think we go
darker i also think like
it doesn't just kill your innocence like
if you're a kid
and you're and you're into like dark
[ __ ] like i remember the first time a
girl touched my
my penis and it was like over my [ __ ]
sweatpants
and she just like touched it a few times
and i came i was like oh my god
and it's like now these kids are going
to be like a woman touches he's like all
right now spit on it
choke me now stick a finger in my ass
right call me a homo or whatever yeah
you got to keep upping it you're right
yeah
but here's here's the rub here's the
irony no pun intended with the rub but
here's the irony
hey that's a good name for a jerk-off
place here's the rub
here's the rub but here's the irony is
you get barbecue and then you get a hand
job you don't want a dry rub
but here's the irony is they did these
studies i don't know who does these
studies but kids are having way less sex
than they used to
a scientist who's about to get fired
he's a guys i just found this out
we're gonna use the data but you can't
work here anymore
exactly that's good that could be a bit
but my point is i think they're not
doing it because they have it
they get it so easily like oh i didn't
get laid by susie q
and in sophomore year i'll just go to
the computer
yeah you're right i mean it's it's all
making us more anti-social like we
talked about it's like the crave for the
likes and the crave for the attention
but it's like
it doesn't make you better yes like not
working for it is good working to get
laid is good you have to have a
meaningful conversation with a woman you
have to
you have to prove that you're not a
scumbag right you have to prove that
you're
able to listen and connect right right
so
you just bring a sex robot in the
equation you're losing that part of your
brain you're like i don't have to try to
be a person anymore
yeah exactly i mean it's the same with
instagram hey i can have a meme
i don't have to be funny to party or
make someone laugh in person or have
timing
or come up with something so yeah i mean
a lot of industry now is creating
anything discomfort
based we figure that out like how to get
rid of that and then people buy it
because they go
i'd rather have a package delivered then
go to the grocery store or go to the
mall
so yeah give me amazon but some of that
[ __ ] is necessary
yeah that discomfort like small talk or
meeting people or seeing people or going
out going to the store seeing all the
groceries grabbing the produce sniffing
the tomato
that's all part of our biology and we're
taking that away
it's a good point it's also like one of
the things we're like we have grandkids
ever
first we have kids but we have grandkids
i mean i think we're pretty good
storytellers we can we can tell a tale
here there you know
as opposed to a regular you know
compared to a regular civilian here
but uh how are our grandkids gonna
listen to us
are they gonna give a [ __ ] about what we
say and we're gonna be like i remember i
used to do comedy with
this guy mark norman right and they're
gonna be on the phone like
uh-huh yeah uh-huh
exactly all right then they're gonna be
like grandpa you're an elephant get in
here get your hat
yeah but you're giving it you gotta go
give it way more technology he's gonna
have like
one little microchip in his eyeball he's
going to go up
well i've watched three movies i saw
breaking bad and my dad blew me while
you were talking about you know
the war so yeah it's gonna be horrible
they're gonna come i think that's gonna
be a thing it's gonna be like vr
and they're just gonna like they're just
gonna not even have to touch their penis
they just like come
they're at the table with their family
like oh they're like stop coming to the
table
that's true and you know you know what
to do to get [ __ ] we had to jerk
ourselves
rapid motion over and over like
what are you amish jesus christ yeah
exactly
you did manual masturbation ah
you drove stick come on
[Laughter]
you're right that's gonna be that we're
[ __ ]
we're so [ __ ] you know what else is
fascinating see we sound like two
boomers
call back i get that i got one of the
guys who i was like you guys shouldn't
be stealing bits and he was like he
wrote
uh one of his friends called wrote dm me
and called me irrelevant that's the one
they love to do you're irrelevant
irrelevant using my [ __ ] how irrelevant
could i be i'm irrelevant you're
stealing my
material exactly and first of all i know
i'm irrelevant but you're still stealing
my [ __ ]
right oh [ __ ] i forgot i was going to
say boomer
boomer boomer oh i lost it
man you are a boomer i'm getting old
what was it hold on it was good ah my
memory's gone
man this [ __ ] white russian goes down
easy i got to tell you i'm a little
jealous this thing sucks
does it well you don't even do you need
the you need you're not making a
cocktail just throwing some bitters
what kind of uh bourbon are you using
i'm using that larceny bourbon that i
got from uh jamie lynn
back to the good stuff yeah i got the
rhine in there
i got the the the circular
ice ball i love a circular i got the
square i got the square ice ball
nice but yeah it's just you know it's
it's okay it's just not my cup
yeah we i like that we can switch this
up i kind of like i love this show
oh yeah it's great damn it what was i
gonna say god was good what are we
holding
boomers at the table manual masturbation
amish
let's drive and stick oh
i came what i came
now
ah [ __ ] all right it's gone gone
uh all right [ __ ] uh boy
we went off on that that was we went
rolling man should we do one more email
should we move on
oh yeah sure let's do another email okay
uh i didn't look at this one let me see
what we got
uh okay hey guys digging the cast is
from jacob
thanks jacob one pet peeve people
announcing
they're gonna say something in a text
instead of just saying the thing
i've got something important to tell you
or i have a question for you
and then there's not saying a thing just
say the thing it's like click bait to
get me to respond to the text and make
me anxious that's a good point
also comedy bit idea i'm not a comic i
mean there's something there too
i got a new sports watch and when i
masturbate it thinks i'm running and so
it's like wow i don't remember taking
3000 steps at midnight last night all
right that's cute
but i think there's something
interesting about the idea of the app
people
the drum roll text as we call it yes
good way to put it you kind of have to
do that now with like
you got to present you're like hey i got
something here you ready for this
you have to because some people get mad
when you don't when you just say like
hey can you do this or whatever and
they're like how about how are you
right right yeah yeah yeah i don't mind
the uh
you ready for this or here's i got one
for you not gonna believe what happened
to me i don't mind that i feel like it
sets it up yeah like i said it could be
a pet peeve
it's a trailer for the movie text yeah
and it also grabs you it gets your
attention you're like all right hit me
it's
like you don't just come in and go i was
robbed you go you're not gonna believe
this [ __ ] i was robbed
well maybe his friends are not giving
them good stories maybe that's the
problem maybe they're going i got
something to tell you and you go what he
goes
i just went to the atm and you're like i
don't give a [ __ ]
maybe that's the problem yeah yeah
that's that could be it
i got a second pet peeve by the way oh
hit me can i do a second pet peeve
please because mine sucks so you gotta
make up for it
i don't like places not serving
breakfast like places that
could serve breakfast all day just being
like i'm done with breakfast like so i
wake up late
so i don't i don't deserve eggs
interesting there's a place down the
block for me and i love it i go there
all the time
this is okay i guess but they go it's an
extra dollar for an
egg sandwich if you go after 11 and it's
like hey guess what guys
the punishment is i get less daylight
okay it's winter
it's dark why are you punishing me here
it's a good point uh it's only a dollar
but it's kind of like it's
it's more the the message the principal
yeah no
yeah i don't like it because it's the
same oven it's just just
you made an egg at 11 58. you can't make
an egg at 1201. like get the [ __ ] out of
here
what did i hate it i hate it yeah i'm a
laborious
i'm a laborizer man and it's like you
know sometimes i'll do a show and i'll
wake up
i'll wake up late it's you know i think
night workers deserve the same respect
that's all i'm saying
good point good point i'll give them the
hey it's it's four we put the eggs away
we put the hollandaise away we put the
bacon away i'll give you that
but this dollar thing that's [ __ ] up
because now you're just
charging me you're making a sale off of
my my
sleep schedule that's great
i'm not asking for hollandaise here i
just want the [ __ ] eggs just give me
the eggs
on a on a uh you know on some toasted
rye
maybe some cheese and avocado that's my
[ __ ] go-to order that's all i want a
simple egg sandwich
yeah no no i feel you go to breakfast by
the way
oh i mean i'm a simple man i like uh
pancakes eggs scrambled
uh sausage and uh you do pancakes daily
no no no no but what's like what's like
your daily do you do
are you a breakfast guy or not oh daily
like you talk about a diner or at my
house
either way at my house every day it's
oatmeal blueberry
and peanut butter whipped up in a mug
love it
every day with a banana on the side
that's good it's a good wholesome good
breakfast
you want to start your day i never got
people like who do a really unhealthy
breakfast
i don't i understand like for me waffles
are like
pancakes that's a 2 a.m diner order
that's not a [ __ ]
10 am dino order i'm not trying to
[ __ ] start my day with that [ __ ]
well who are these people who don't
realize that a waffle covered in syrup
or pancakes or french toast
i mean you're just eating birthday cake
at 9 00 a.m that's all that is
but they it's they disguise even a
muffin is just it's it's
basically a cupcake it's all the same
[ __ ]
my grandma used to crush man blueberry
muffins they would be the best
best thing you ever eaten in your life
look i get i love them i love them to
death but uh
they're just eating this horrible sweets
in the morning and they call it
breakfast so
it's okay isn't that crazy i was
watching i was watching kramer versus
kramer the other night
uh i've i don't know why i've seen that
movie so many times it's such a sad
movie but like i love it for some reason
like
you know i mean just it's hoffman and
meryl streep what's not to like it's
incredible but uh i feel like your tv is
stuck on
turner classic movies and you can't get
it off get the remote's broken i guess
we're stuck on tmc
well there's one scene where dustin
hoffman his kids are just eating like
enemies chocolate donuts for breakfast
yeah it's donuts i get that he's i get
that he's going through a divorce but
it's like that's a [ __ ]
that's an aggressive breakfast for such
a slender frame i was surprised
yeah you ever think about like how
great it was to not know like why did no
one knew that
donuts were bad for you bread was
fattening sugar was bad
they were bad well i don't know i mean
maybe they did but like people were like
i i smoked a cigarette i ate two eggs
every morning and six pieces of bacon
and pancakes and i went to work at the
mill
and you're like and i lived to 104 but
they didn't know about carbs and
uh sweets and simple sugars and fatty
acids and all that [ __ ]
that's a good point yeah i think they
were probably more about moderation
they're like well i just had like a
little donut that's how my grandpa was
he's like
he just said to my mom he's like well
you eat so much but you're like so thin
and she's like i'm eating fruit i'm not
eating like you're eating like one big
donut
yeah yeah glazed donut that's insane but
then again people died at like 63. i
miss a donut though man you ever just
hit up like
the donut pub on like 14. they did that
louis episode remember okay so the kid
that's a new york kid who bullies louie
in that episode yeah
he's on the sopranos too uh mikey's a
friend of mine he's befriending my
friend dan he's a great guy but like
louie would always go there that
doughnut pub and i remember like you
know stav and i would go there rachel
and i would go there it's like
you just go there you get a car a night
coffee
yep [ __ ] loaded don't you get a bacon
donut like all right for me for me that
stuff is like
the best and i can't just can't start my
day that way but end of the night
i'm all in i'm not judging anyone's
lifestyle choice
well yeah you're already drunk you're
hammered it's it's a sinful time
the lights are off you know you're
smoking again that's what it is
we're judging sin in the daylight ah
what do you open your [ __ ] morning
banging a hooker too i mean [ __ ]
yeah yeah there's a difference between
sin and cinnamon
wait no i [ __ ] that up forget i said
it
oh geez that was bad but but no you're
right it's morning and you're having a
[ __ ]
stack of flapjacks with with liquid
sugar and butter
what are your nuts damn a blueberry
pancake though man those are what's your
go-to is it are you a chocolate chip
pancake
oh no no blueberry chocolate chip is
overkill it's like dude
it's already sweet enough what are you
crazy it's like a speed ball
yeah you need heroin and speed just do
the heroin
[Laughter]
but yeah no oh yeah nothing better than
a diner and that donut
it's open i went with salacuse last week
and just that wall of donuts the bar
with the
round stools that place is special
that's a new york
uh classic there's like a few more
classic places where you're like oh this
is like
a classic donut coffee place or
something like that warms your heart
it's very
there's something like very welcoming
about it we're like i just sit and eat
my donut and i have my coffee
and i feel like i could write jokes in
here could write jokes it's quiet but
it's not quiet it's perfect it's like a
donut library you got all of them up on
the wall
and the the ladies got the old cashier
and me and salakis were making fun of
hilaria baldwin and it was like a
classic new york moment
i'm talking to this brooklyn guy we're
talking about hilaria baldwin and the
cashier was hispanic and she goes
we all make fun of her and this
a jump in i love when you're kind of
shooting the [ __ ] and you get a stranger
with a good ad lib
i love you yes that feels very like it
feels very new york to me but
i'm sure it happens everywhere but no no
no new york
but the worst is when you get a stranger
chime in and it's negative you're like
hey who invited you here dick let's
we're trying to have a conversation
you know he's like that's not true
actually it was 19 years
get out of here oh like that i love that
annie hall scene when he's just in line
and he's just listening to that [ __ ]
imbecile blather on it you're like oh
that's such a great
the loud [ __ ] who thinks they're
right about everything
and you're like well you already lack
awareness enough to be a loud [ __ ]
clearly your opinions on things are
going to be [ __ ] also
yeah brilliant scene because then he has
the professor come in and prove him
right
i love it [ __ ] that's such a great
what's your no what's your number one
woody at
give me your top five woody allen right
top five
hey i don't even they don't even need to
be in order just give me your favorite
five
i mean out of the gate it's crimes and
misdemeanors and hannah and her sisters
are the top
two for me we're on the same page but i
got you gotta throw in any hall just
because it's annie hall
respect best rom-com of all time or up
there
uh i love uh take the money and run just
so many great
jokes [ __ ] i love it that's in your five
manhattan is good but it's uh
i like the comedy ones maybe nah well
hannah says isn't that funny
it's deconstructing harry too i like
match point i like i like vicky
barcelona i mean
i'm all over the road here so where are
you so you're take the money and run
crimes and misdemeanors
annie hall and uh one of the other
sisters
and her sisters and then i need one more
so i might i might go manhattan
manhattan is great i probably do the
same thing but i swap out uh
take the money and run and i go bullets
over broadway
that's just like that might be like in
my top five comedies it's [ __ ]
that's a great movie i mean that diner
scene with the [ __ ]
old jewish comics is is that's broadway
danny rose
oh what am i saying oh that you're
talking about the gangster one where
they're running
yeah yeah that's a great one it's just
the diane wiese is just brilliant
i love her she's great she's great she
scared the [ __ ] out of me in superman
too
i don't remember in that i never saw
that i don't think it's horrible don't
even don't even bother richard pryor's
in it or maybe it's three but it's
it's a mess she uh yeah apparently i
used to play with her kid in the
playground when i was like a baby my mom
was like she loved you
diane wow i was like that's my she like
baby me
that's your aunt if you ever meet her i
used to
i used to play with your kid in the
playground yeah don't say the age just
be like i just play with your kid
yesterday yeah i was 31
yeah what's it what's your rack is it
are you going search party this week or
do you have something else
no no you already did that so uh my
wreck is gonna be
so there's this new documentary out on
on netflix called
the night stalker oh is it good
it's amazing but that's not my wreck you
should watch it i'm kind of doing a
double wreck here but it's it's
incredibly done but this guy tiller
russell
is the director and he's a documentarian
but he adds his own
spice to it like he makes the music and
he cuts it up beautifully he's almost
like the tarantino of directors
of documentaries and he did another one
called operation odessa unreal
i mean watch it tonight if you can it's
on netflix
it's the story is so unbelievable it's
all real is footage
it you don't believe what you're seeing
it feels written it's too
perfect damn i just looked it up all
right interesting
it's basically these three gangsters
one's a russian gangster who opens a
nightclub in miami
he meets a foreign car salesman like
lamborghini ferrari
salesman in miami they all do blow and
they meet this
uh south american gangster and they buy
a russian
sub when they soviet uh what do you call
the ussr fell the soviet union
and everything went cheap so they bought
a russian sub and packed it with coke
and they would ride it back and forth
from i mean it's unreal and they're all
over the top they're all crazy
characters
you gotta watch it like that all right
i'm gonna watch it i'll watch it tonight
um my wreck is uh so i told you like
for whatever reason my focus has been
[ __ ] since the pandemic started like
my add is already terrible but then uh i
mean i feel like
i'm talking like a close friend like you
i can focus but
i mean just in general if i'm reading a
book my anxiety i have such bad anxiety
i'm depressed i'm just you know i'm
doing my best to just
focus elsewhere so noir is such a good
escape for me i was
reading short stories because i feel
like if i finish a short story i'm like
i completed something tonight so i read
a bunch of these uh
in this book uh it's called manhattan
noir
it's a short storybook manhattan noir
there's also an la noir that's very good
and there's also manhattan war
ii but one of the ones i love in
manhattan noir
i'm going to give a spoiler for one of
them so i'm sorry but it's just very
cool
hit me so the plot it's a short story
but the plot is basically that
this guy keeps killing people this guy
just like homeless people just keep
winding up dead and these cops are like
who the [ __ ] is doing this like who
keeps killing
these homeless people and it's like
they're like we don't know so
they keep winding up and they cops kind
of put together where it's happening and
they kind of find a pattern
and one of the cops decides to go
undercover
as a homeless person to bust the guy
so he pick he finds this guy he's just
laying there and this guy walks up to
him one night and goes
oh you look like you're not doing well
do you want a cigarette and it's like a
creepy looking dude
and he's in boat shoes like a rich
[ __ ] and
the cop goes he's hiding he's a homeless
guy he basically says you know yeah yeah
i'll take a cigarette and the guy takes
out the pack and he notices when he
opens the pack
one of them is the wrong way and he's
just like
and he hands him the one that's going
the wrong way and he goes
you smoked that one oh and he goes
what are you talking about why he goes i
think you should smoke that one
and the guy goes i don't want to and he
takes out a gun he goes smoke that
[ __ ] cigarette right now
and the guy is like quivering and
basically he puts he knows that he's
poisoning people
he knows he's poisoning people with a
[ __ ] and the guy starts crying and he's
basically just like
i'm not like i i i i feel like i'm
helping them i'm trying to put them out
of their misery they're homeless you
know
and it's this dark [ __ ] and he puts a
gun to his [ __ ] head
and says smoke the [ __ ] cigarette you
piece of [ __ ] because he's murdering
people and the guy smokes it
and then he takes off his clothes and
puts the guy in the homeless clothes so
when they find him they think it was
just another homeless person that was
murdered
well it seems like a vigilante yeah wow
[ __ ] cool though isn't that cool
that's super cool but let me ask you
because you read a lot more of these
than i do
do you think that guy came up with that
and said i gotta write a story around
this or did he come up with a hobo that
that's what's so fascinating i'm not a
i'm not a i'm not a murder mystery right
what the [ __ ] do i don't know they write
this stuff i i don't know i mean like
how do you come up with a bit right is
it yeah i guess so but
maybe yeah maybe maybe i don't yeah
maybe i think some of them
i would guess know the ending and right
backward would
might would be my
because if he wrote anything before that
and then came up with that ending i mean
that would be too impressive
that's a good point i thought it was
just a [ __ ] badass turn
that is a great turn a great twist i
mean just to think about the cigarette
thing
that's man that's really great it was
badass i love
i love cool twists um
all right how about a news story any
good news oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah you you go uh you go first i gotta
pull mine up here
so i got um i don't have anything good
but i do
we do have to mention that phil spector
died i think that's like big news
yeah crazy that guy's a piece of [ __ ]
murderer yeah do you do you like his
work or now
well he did all the george harrison
stuff right i [ __ ] love all things
must pass
i mean one of the best albums of all
time he he did all the wall of sound
[ __ ]
yeah yeah he did the worst leonard cone
album he did death of a ladies man
uh which is like the album is dreadful
and leonard cohen wanted nothing to do
with it
and same with the ramones i think the
ramones were also like [ __ ] you we want
nothing to do with you but leonard cohen
was like i hate this guy he would like
take out guns during recording sessions
i read this in his book he was like he
would take guns out during recording
sessions and be like
and just put on the table to [ __ ] with
him like he was a piece of [ __ ]
whoa but then all these other people
like he's a genius
but uh leonard cohn basically when the
album was done he was like i want
nothing to
like imagine putting out a w an album
being like i
i disown this i want nothing to do with
it but i will say this
throw on the song death of a ladies man
10-minute track by leonard cohen
it's insanely good really the lyrics are
just like
[ __ ] insane it's epic it's almost got
like a tune to almost like man and me by
bob dylan but it's like but it's 10
minutes
and yeah give it a listen
all right we'll do death of a ladies man
yeah and also the one thing i'll say
about this
veronica uh uh ronnie spector
is his ex-wife uh-huh phil spector's
ex-wife
veronica bennett of the ronettes
so you know he made all those gronette
hits yeah
but like that's that's like the downside
of taking a murderer's
last name is now she's just ronnie
spector forever you know
yeah that's like it's like if your last
name is like simpson or like [ __ ] uh
kennedy or something right right she's
like well my middle name was
chappaquiddick or something like that
yeah yeah uh suzy 911
wait a minute yeah so what was his
genius i mean obviously he had great
taste and he had a great ear but like
you know jimmy iovine and all these guys
they're like they've discovered
metallica they discovered
dr dre and all this [ __ ] or whatever it
was this fleetwood mac
uh but what did he do okay so i don't
know music like
a lot of like so i feel almost guilty
trying to explain this because i
people can be like sam you're a [ __ ]
idiot but i think due to my limited
understanding of spectre i think it was
that he was able to combine
like almost like darkness in a pop
way where he could well he could like
bring about
it was like big everything was he did
one i think he didn't let it be by the
beatles
but it was like it was like a bigger
sound than it would have been
and i think paul mccartney was also like
[ __ ] you it should have been less
i think they he's another guy who is not
thrilled with how it turned out but uh
yeah i think he made things sound way
bigger and i think that's probably why
cohn didn't like it i mean this was like
free his synthesizer phase which also
was like not my favorite atlanta code
phases but uh i think the [ __ ] just
sounded big
yeah interesting but also he would do
with dark music but then he also did i
get with like the ronettes which isn't
that those songs don't seem dark to me
you know yeah yeah i just never know
what those guys do
like i know david geffen used to go down
to the troubadour you know back in the
70s and be like this
guy is gonna be it it was like a young
elton john you know
but other than that i don't know what
these guys do so that's interesting that
he he changed the sound
yeah fascinating yeah i know people that
work with him
like swear he's a genius they say all
right but then you also hear stories
like that where they're like he's a
[ __ ] horrible human being and i mean
clearly he is a horrible human being
he's a murderer he murdered
an innocent woman he got drunk and then
he killed he shot her in the head in a
chair
and then he went outside and i think he
told his driver something like i think i
murdered someone i mean he's insane he's
an insane person
jesus was he on a date i think they got
i think they got drunk and they just
went back to his place is the story
wow well he's got to do everything big
uh all right so i don't know if you
heard this is a true story this sounds
like a setup for a joke
and it's a real news story the wealthy
sweet and low magnate
leaps to death from nyc apartment
and so i mean the the bits in my head
were just ringing like a like a
casino uh like a slot machine uh so i
the one i went i'm not gonna sugarcoat
it but
the one i went with was after death
we're all equal
that's good yeah that's funny how about
how about
sad and high
[Laughter]
he had a real sugar crash
but there's so many but i went with uh
we're all equal and it got got
about 200 retweets so i feel pretty good
about it that's good that's funny
all right what do you got should we do a
bit well is that your news
yeah i just i feel like we just had to
touch on specter we're going long anyway
oh okay okay okay let's do it what's
should i do a bit or you want to do a
bit uh hit me hit me
i got a couple i want to pick the one i
like i have a thing about how i have
like really
i've talked with such bad atd so i think
i like women who are emotionally fragile
because they keep me engaged you know
what i mean like i have a hard time
paying attention if someone's crying all
the time like all right i'm locked in
it's like it's like someone talks about
their day it doesn't feel urgent but if
someone starts shrieking i'm like
this seems time sensitive right right
yeah you're watching an action movie
when they're talking you don't give a
[ __ ] but when that car explodes you're
like all right i'm paying attention i'm
back in
yeah this is speed this is something
like that yeah there's something like
that there yeah yeah
yeah there's something there
carmen lynch has that bit about ever
listening to a story
and it's boring but then there's one
good part you're like could you repeat
that could you go back you have to
pretend like you
you were listening because okay but
that's i don't think that's that similar
though is it
completely different completely i'm just
saying you don't want to tread in that
area but totally
i won't go there she's i love carmen oh
yeah
today's her birthday believe it or not
oh [ __ ] yeah
if you haven't seen uh the hilarious
carmen lynch
uh give a give a youtube search to her
letterman sets she's she's a killer
such smart deadpan jokes yeah
and i'm sure she's got albums out there
too so she got an album i think that
just came out check it out
she does yeah a couple letterman's an
album
she's done a few things i think she's
got a colbert
she's done she's done yeah i think like
chord and she's done a ton of [ __ ] yeah
yeah good egg all right is this
this is completely raw or maybe a
horrible idea maybe you can help me with
it
so i had a thought about church you know
all these people like i want to go to
church but it's coveted blah blah and i
thought isn't church
weird that it's all about jesus and god
but they're not even there you know it's
weird to go
uh like we do zoom because we can't meet
up
but people go to church is it's kind of
like a god
zoom because he's not there
so it's like you're going to a concert
to see this guy who's not even going to
be there
yeah he's like he's like axel rose
you're like where is he [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah no he's coming back you're
like well he's
when but but it's weird to go to a show
with the guy you're a fan of and worship
isn't even there but the publicist is
there
he's going like this is what he said i'm
delivering the news
yeah i don't know if it's funny but i
thought that was interesting you're
going to see a show with the guy who's
not even there that you worship
he's like yeah he's your hype man it's
like seeing public enemy but it's just
flavor flav
yeah yeah exactly and he tells you what
to do it's almost like wave your hands
in the air except it's get on your knees
and
you know read this psalm yeah it's not
as catchy
right why not just pray at home why do
you have to go to the place
yeah it's kind of maybe if you do the
guns rose angle it's kind of like
paradise city but uh you better be good
you're not going to go there
right right yeah yeah maybe heaven is
the after party
yeah it's i love the angle that god is
not
he's not even there like what a great
idea what a [ __ ] it's like doing like
a public appearance thing and he's like
ah i can't make it can you can you cover
for me
right right and he's such a big
celebrity that
you still keep showing up like you feel
like if you like ariana grande
you wouldn't go to the concert 15 times
you'd be like all right she's not coming
[ __ ] it
it's basically a true it's basically a
tribute band it's a tribute
kiss is so big you're like i'll go see
someone play kiss
right that's interesting that's what it
is tribute band is the angle i think
that's good all right yeah
yeah yeah it's not jesus it's pastor
john or whoever yeah
and it's uh i like the idea that he
can't
because the other thing is you know he's
not gonna make it
right right yeah that's true and we're
just playing his hits
you're playing his hits cause you're
singing all the songs in unison with the
whole
other you know church-goers and that's
kind of like the
the best the greatest hits
yeah it it you're right it's it is i
think the angle is like a concert
where it's like it's it's a tribute band
it's a concert
uh it's almost like this is maybe a
weird angle to go but like
someone is it's if you did like a
michael jackson type thing because it's
like
he's gone anyway you know he's not going
to show up be like but these are [ __ ]
good teams right right yeah yeah
i still love michael jackson even though
he's problem is problem is maybe you go
prince because michael jackson's got
that guilt connected to it
well then you get the kid [ __ ]
connection though that's [ __ ] true
michael jackson good call he was more
than just kid [ __ ]
now we're getting somewhere this is good
i think we got something here some of
there well let me let me think back to
your bit
the ability you like an emotional lady
because yeah
you're only locked in when she's crying
yeah i like i like drama i don't want to
admit it to myself but i like a little
drama
all right all right i mean shiver it's
it's almost like i'm watching myself
watch a show
and you're like you ever just it's like
would you rather watch [ __ ]
downton abbey or the [ __ ] sopranos
you know what i mean i want [ __ ] to
happen
yeah i wonder if there's a uh
parallel with sex like dude you got a
black guy like i need to be hit in bed
or i i i can't get off
and it's the same with a woman like you
need to be yelled at or are you not
paying attention
not yelled at i just need some thing to
be roped and like [ __ ] i don't like
putting this info on blast here because
i don't want to keep
attracting that yeah but you're going to
attract it anyway i mean that's what
you're into
yeah there's something about needing
i think it's also like needing to fix i
think that's also what it is
it's like there's a need to fit i almost
feel like
i almost feel like a mechanic sometimes
if you bring me something and it's i'm
like yeah it's fine what do you want me
to do with it you know i mean
it's something that's got to be a little
off yeah
yeah it's like you're flipping houses
you want the the fl
the fix that's not the intent i'm not
trying to flip it
i'm trying to keep the house that's a
good point i think the house is going to
leave me
so i gotta flip it good point yeah cars
is better you want to fix the rubber and
then you drive the car
but every now and then that oil is going
to that oil valve is going to go down or
the
gas leak it could be an apartment
because you're kind of like here's the
thing about the apartment
is that you could be like well you're
like how did i get this deal and you're
like
then you move in you're like the last
guy did a number that's how i did you
know or something right
or you do something along the lines of
like i always like the idea of like
apartments
versus like dating apps where it's like
the pictures are a lie
but then you get there and you're like
all right i'll give it a shot
and then like two months in you're just
like the sync doesn't work the heat
doesn't work
this [ __ ] the lighting's not good and
then they're like yeah i lied
it was a lot right right yeah
zillow and tinder are very similar
street easy that could be a good
prostitute
i think you're right the apartment thing
could lead into this
yeah there's a lot there i mean there's
a lot to play with if you want to get
married you could buy
you know you're renting now but if you
want to make it serious now you're
buying and your friend's like you're
gonna buy with that
the [ __ ] uh the pipes aren't even
working you're like i know i'm gonna fix
them
[Applause]
all right all right this is getting too
heavy we got some stuff i mean it was a
hot
we went long we always go long on this
show i feel like no we go along there's
no set time so there is no long but
there's no that's a good bit
what uh what do you got what do you got
coming up uh oklahoma i'm doing
something good
some gigs i'm scattered all over the
place oklahoma you're careful in
oklahoma
oh yeah lots of love to okc i'm at
stress factory february 2nd
or 4th through 6th rather oh great it's
outdoors but he did yeah i'm pumped
gotcha have you you've been there new
jersey i went there once just to pop in
because i was doing a show in jersey
already but
i haven't done a weekend since the
pandemic there but uh
yeah i'm pumped all new material so
unless i start bombing then i'll break
out some of the oldies well yeah it's
it's a hot setup
it feels like a real club list likes it
better than the old one which is
hilarious
that's hilarious i like that i like
performing i like doing a little jersey
action oh yeah new brunswick's all right
i'm also there
in february two i don't know i think
maybe february third then i'm at soul
joel's again
in february oh that's incredible 16th so
yeah a lot a lot of gigs coming warriors
royersford pa shout out to soldier the
man
what a great thing he's doing over there
in p.a he's great
love soul joel he did a hilarious thing
to me by the way uh
came over to me came over to me when i
was there and was like man ever since
big j got punched uh and dragged off
stage like
it just blew the show right up and i'm
like you shouldn't be bragging about
that that's not something you come up to
people and are like
proud of that's a [ __ ] up thing that
happened to jay
of course but i will say in this [ __ ]
up
wacko circus of a business we're in uh
if you have some kind like bill burr
that
philly rant kind of broke him jim
jeffries
yeah but arranged and adapting to a
horrible crowd is different than being
assaulted
i agree i agree i'm just my point is it
also it's hilarious with the guy who
runs the show to be like
i gotta you notice these numbers are
pretty good right you know what happened
hey it's tough how these these guys will
take any any help they can get but
he's done a great job he's done a great
job for sure done a great job
this business is weird any kind of
exposure you can get i mean sometimes
getting canceled
you know in a weird way can help some
people i don't know i'm just saying
it's not getting carried away here
that's positive sometimes to a negative
jim jeffries punched out on stage went
viral that's true
that was a big one bill burke still to
this day says i thought that philly
thing was gonna ruin my career
oh it was incredible i remember being
blown away by it and just thinking he
had like the most balls of any comic
ever it was just i i remember being
completely like
oh that's that's a dude i love forever
now
yeah there were people and also for
giving love to don morera who they
[ __ ] that [ __ ] disrespectful yeah
yeah hazie's the man he's a killer comic
and uh
but screw him and come see us
joking don't screw him but i'm just
saying just trying to end on a bang here
no this has been hot man i love doing
this we'll keep it going and uh remember
to uh subscribe on
apple uh one more drink with mark and
sam that's the one that's us we'll keep
it going we got a producer now
uh keep emailing us at uh
one more drink with mark and sam at
gmail and subscribe to the patreon.com
one more drink pod subscribe to that
cause uh
bonus apps and you can email us and
we'll read those
on the uh patreon so thank you for
supporting and uh we really appreciate
you guys
thank you and tell a liquor company
goddammit let's get a sponsor let's get
some sponsors if you work for a liquor
company hit us the [ __ ] up
we'll promote your [ __ ] at a cost
here here toodles thank you bye